good morning we're at the home of
professor and mrs. gurgi capisce in
Camrys cambridge massachusetts professor
kalisch is a hardest educator author
founder and first director of the center
for advanced digital studies at MIT 21
years ago I received a grant to visit
the professor Kepesh at MIT and learn
more about the center
I did not come then for a number of
reasons however I am here now it's
indeed a pleasure to finally meet you
make your acquaintance
professor capiche this interview is
about or the reason for the interview at
this time is that the California College
of California Polytechnic State
University in San Luis Obispo California
is having a show at the student gallery
directed by dr. mrs. dr. Gina Barbra and
since you were unable to visit us for
the opening of the show and present to
present your ideas I was asked to come
here and some might document some words
that you may have for the audience of
the community in California the show is
about the winning of art and science in
service to to society to community
originally I first heard of your dream
and when I read some articles and
magazine or a couple of magazines and my
interest was annoying what was your what
were your original intentions your
dreams I mean in terms of goals and
objectives would you just elaborate on
that I really try but this you know all
this kind of confrontation is once inner
realities and outside world it's not an
easy assignment
maybe I should start with a mini
autobiography I grew up in as much as a
child in Hungary and my involvement is
life was a hardship of life I grew up
first after the first world war and it
had many both tragedies and hopes
usually when you are seeing very dark
then you have at least dreams of much
light and so that was my own life always
confronting with a sadness or the
tragedies of social and personal life
and I was hoping to compensate was a
missing part by dreaming about much
better words than I had and so my
interest in art was not just the
personal subjective and kind of anger
about a misplaced existence but a dream
about an optimum existence and so since
my early youth I had always utopian
dreams how to converge whatever we have
in this life and utilize all means and
all tools and all equipment include
realizing and richer better more honest
life and we can have these artists extra
scaffolding of existence as I know now
for many years of practice my English is
still Hungarian and if you feel I
derailed from logic Laurie understanding
please interrupt me and ask new
questions so for the time being that
should be it
originally when I mentioned that 21
years ago I applied for a grant to come
to to visit you my primary reason for
that is I - and extremely interested in
in art as a means of raising social
consciousness my parents came from
Mexico as farmworkers and I grew in
Kansas and when I read of your
intentions of bringing about social
change that attracted me extremely
because that still remained the Serra
most in my efforts and Marta sztyc
efforts how were you specifically
through your Center going to resist or
raise social and environmental
consciousness that is an ecological
awareness
what were the the processes that you're
going to pursue maybe like everybody
then one has a distant goal has to set
priorities and when I had these utopian
hope to create conditions which will
optimize one's existence i had to
recognize that in a certain way we are
shaped by our environment and so my
priority was to create an artistic
awareness of the positive and negative
aspect of our environment and I was
fully aware I was an addict of William
Morris and O Ruskin and 90 setting
dreamers and I knew that living and
growing up in 19th century slums was
some had some role in setting the goals
of this great old thinker or dreamers in
a word which has richer environment and
so my own goals and dreams were shaped
by these know
to be a full human being you have two
conditions which lets you grow up for it
and so my baby dreams where and I use a
term again to find living condition
which optimizes one's awareness of what
is wrong and try to set targets of what
could be better and could be richer I
was an addict of Miriam Morrison Ruskin
in this time it was a rather neglected
area of dreaming and so I try to find
goals which she was starting from Raskin
Maurice and Carlisle and some of the 90s
and the dreamers and try to go not
beyond but try to rein force their
dreams with greater honest reality and
so my interest was to create this
education or through the education and
art and living condition which seems to
project once neglected dreams which was
to create an environment which gives
individual human the chance to be fully
human and so that's in a nutshell in a
cracked nutshell my early dreams you
mentioned in one of your writings that
coming to MIT and Harvard area that the
cultural times were right or right for
you to establish this Center what do you
mean by the cultural times were right
for the establishment of your Center I'm
always concerned when I'm at confirm
there is my own statement because one
dramatized exaggerates beliefs and
conditions
but I meant that I survived that we
their Rosa
dislocated from our better self and one
sees light only in darkness I know it
sounds paradox but is not my paradox it
was master or myself
account agreed 1913 century German
dreamer who said so
and what he may have meant at least as I
can see was that you cannot really see
were clear a self disorder seeing the
negation of your best self
and I thought after the Second World War
and all these bloody difficulties but my
generation or a bit older than my
generation had to go through has to be
corrected and the best way of correcting
was or could have been if he faced what
we don't have from the full humaneness
and the full humaneness is that we have
all the intensity and richness of
England a life without neglecting social
obligation and that seems to be the
crisis or critical aspect of our
existence a 19th century project that a
great deal of honest big dreams and
these big dreams were derailed and the
reality was far from these dreams and as
you are coming from Mexico did you grow
up in Mexico no my parents are civil or
from Mexico I was born in the in the
barrio of Kansas City I see
so but the the practices the cultural
practices of my parents were
prevalent the dominant men are in her
home in any case maybe Suzie reflected
light you could sense the richness of
the Mexican small scale of existence
definitely and and so when you form your
own dreams these dreams were partly
woven around these early experiences
what you partly got or inherited from
your parents
and I had a little similar condition
that I had my own childhood dreams of a
rich life which was fresh air blue sky
honest human relationship and in this
condition I recognized when I came to
MIT that we have all the means or tools
but to miss the essential part of it and
so my target when I came to MIT had to
modify it because I saw a means but I
observe the hard targets we had not
anymore there I I believe that that is
what has always in reading your writings
your books articles that core that sense
that each described of more simpler ways
a more extensive community in your home
life and hungry and then
and my home life in Kansas although it
was Kansas it was still a Mexican
household we practiced our extensive
community and togetherness we were from
a large family and those are the things
that has to this very day in reading
your material as always correspondent
has kept me connected and where I have
learned so much from your writings and
practiced using your theories to
underpin my work again the core of my
work deals with bringing about social
change as you can see I am a person of
color and we are in this country where
where there are these kinds of problems
a matter of fact having to do with color
of people you establish the center of
advanced visual studies in ninth in the
mid 60's 1967 this was in the midst of
the civil rights movement to be followed
by the various movements of a free
speech at UC Berkeley University of
California Berkeley then of course there
could follow the the the environmental
movement not necessarily in that order
the women's movement I personally am a
member of the United Farm Workers and
attempting to bring about a better life
a stronger life a more equity in this
country do you have any specific
instances in the work that has been done
by the fellows who you brought to your
Institute or any of the work done by
others that that directly deals with
social change can you think of any
specific instances not in this centre
but in the family or daughter who as a a
who is not actually involved in what
they and the environment issues and
is partly moving forth of the urban
garden movement here she went to the
South during the difficult times and she
was arrested and she went through the
whole kind of feeling the full strength
of the trouble and as we are very close
to closely knit family I felt very
strongly what she felt or she felt wrong
with my wife and myself and so I always
had a strong sense of the under dog or
the difficulties and also in my own
experiences
I grew up born and grew up in the if one
can call it growing up in the early part
of the century and I felt a great deal
of the ideas what was expressed in you
sure you know the music of béla bartók
and I felt also a great sympathy and
involvement in the ideas that art has a
major role in transforming the inner
self and we saw the inner transformation
seems to be not very hopeful to
transform the outside world and so my
own commitment was the transformation or
hoping to contribute to the
transformation of inner self and
hopefully the future with the quality of
experiences to shift gears and try to
mobilize the social forces to make
changes in the outside world and I
assume everything is basically
interconnected and whatever I did in my
own life it was always not integrated
but in term or by the opposite factors
the inner life is external world
and the extent milord is enroute that
looks really interesting because as I
sit here and look around this room all
the the art the artifacts that I see
here are artifacts that are interwoven
are a part of life integrated with life
the crafts the rugs the weaving so this
this type of thing but and at the same
time I notice a complete absence of the
so-called modern art that some people
look at it as being artists commodity
you have art here as ideology the facet
of ideology and but I don't I don't see
the artists commodity is this the reason
in other words that you at is very
difficult to point the finger and a
single sector which makes one's life
values but I feel and my wife has the
same need that whatever we had around us
should be radiating this quality of life
which is coming from a committed
existence and some houses simple art
forms the owners crafts firms have this
inner radiation on the positive sense at
least for us and what we have this of
the top with Peruvian fabric wishes may
be almost dozen years old and I think
there are great pieces of art I don't
really know the book of Boris Franz boas
primitive art I learned from this book a
great deal about Peruvian art and so
whatever I have around here is a
conglomeration of everything which added
to my own sensory clarification in one
of your writings you mentioned
professor accomplished the idea that you
and your colleagues many times felt
frustrated that that ideas were often
clipped you would like to see these
ideas fulfilled
I suppose what that meant was that some
of the the the students or others would
would have a seed that looked as though
it was about ready to bloom given
blossom to something powerful that dealt
with the ecological consciousness and
then it perhaps died out or was
translated into some as commodity or
some kind of a product for making money
etc and the objective of your Center
your dream was was again perhaps
centered on this social environmental
change consciousness I know because of
my own personal experience that
California which is incidentally about
50% people of color who are very
interested in social change equity part
of the American piece of the American
Dream etc etc well would find
particularly the artists your your
writings that you did 21 years ago and
beyond that extremely important to their
work now the theories to underpin their
work in the broader large-scale context
that is the urban environment I believe
that because of the present social
environmental crisis and what we know as
the paradigm shift in terms of design
that is the paradigm shift that is of
viewing the world again is an organism
rather than as a mechanism the way we
begin to view it right after the
Industrial Revolution that your your
your work will receive an extreme amount
of of
how shall I say put a popularity
importance in the work of these artists
they're now facing the future and must
in some way confront this abyss that we
are at this moment California
Polytechnic State University which is
located halfway between Los Angeles and
San Francisco it's extremely interested
in that it is an environmental center
where the people are very seriously
concerned about their and their
environment
what are your thoughts on that do you
how do you see this I know that you have
not visited or lived in California that
as you visited from time to time but
nature's that I fully understand the
question that I answered the real
question you want to know what my
responses to the present situation in
California that's I have to be butting
Roman coal rot as a future seeing to
give a valid answer I think as far as I
can judge it from here
California has an incredible complex
population and more mobile than any
other part of this country or maybe any
other part of the world and consequently
the for casting of what is the major
social task and reading the present
situation one has to have a clearer
sense of living and maybe I put it in
other way in order to give a valid
comment of observation I had to know
more about present California and
whatever I know is from my very last
trip which was maybe 20 years ago
renovate was and some of the newspaper
comments which is always just echoes of
echoes and never has a clear notion of
reality but my guess is
California has an incredible complex
social situation and the fact that you
and coming from a Mexican family could
be what you are it implies as the
potentials are immense and that in the
middle of this kind of turmoil what we
live in a twenty century you have a
maybe a better chance to send the pulse
of life than any other part of the world
it was not as a most lucid comment but
in any case the feeling was in Cal Poly
San Luis Obispo is very well known for
the students the young scientists
engineers etc that they are producing
and it seems to me that by wearing those
efforts of technology with art whose
function it is to alter consciousness
would not only broaden their
perspectives allow them to contribute to
the welfare of society but as you
mentioned here in our conversation give
them more humaneness not exactly those
words that you put them but but a more
nurse to their humanity and I am hoping
that and right now it's happening that
the liberal arts are being emphasized
are being encouraged but I have a sense
that that that that some of the students
in the sciences don't
may not quite appreciate what does the
liberal arts have to give them how does
it broaden them how does it give them
more power make it more socially
environmentally responsible I fully
understand what you referred to because
when I came to MIT had a similar feeling
MIT was during the time I came the very
end of the Second World War it was
religious the arsenal of the world it
had a tremendous competence in producing
intelligent weapons
basalt heart and so when I came I was
practically shocked but I was lucky
enough because I had a few good friends
at MIT administration and I discovered
that they are with us in the sense they
feel also a great social loyalty and
they are seeking like you or I was
seeking before implementing this loyalty
in real life and not just dreaming and
projecting sometime utopian dreams but
try to find the real means to bring it
to concrete social reality and I still
feel that schools like yours and mine or
MIT had an immense and still has an
immense role in piloting not just
knowledge was the heart of the knowledge
and create circumstances which will
raise the level of awareness of all
problems not just artistic problems but
all problems and I feel fortunate in my
life to be invited to MIT I was there I
came there in 45 and that's a long time
ago and I never disappoint and there are
naturally narrow-minded people
everywhere including a fair-minded
and so I feel a lucky man to be able to
be a participant in MIT search for AI
and Latin of reality and I made close
friendship with some of the real major
figures at MIT and I learned from them a
great deal not in terms of technical or
scientific knowledge but in their big
road or their nests of the issues what
you are referring to in California there
is an assemblyman in Sacramento which is
a cat his name is John Vasconcellos he
has implemented a program a task force
that deals with raising the self-esteem
of citizens of the state of California
it's a task force the governor did
meijin approved a couple of years ago
more or less several millions of dollars
to support this program
the task force every county in the state
of California is encouraged to have a
local task force committee it seems to
me that using your philosophy your
theories your writings etc as the
underpinning structure for using the
human built environment the cultural
landscape in order to dignify the lives
of all people the pluralistic society to
empower them rather than to its disable
them which has been the practice by many
the way you control people as you lower
the self esteem you deny them their the
culture you die them their their history
and consequently as you fragment them
and destroy the community and you can
control them and this is in the minds of
many people it's part of what we call
institutional racism now the idea is to
reintegrate these people to make use of
history
the team that deals with the history of
these people the so called minorities
who is not history that has not been
taught and the vehicle the medium of the
human built environment coupled with the
liberal arts taught that our
universities throughout would play a
central role of all this but it must
start there in the curriculum and
students taking courses in liberal arts
etc but there you have a wedding of in
my opinion of Science and Arts being
underpinned with your very good work at
the beginning many people buried here
hopes thank you very much i I want to
thank you professor cafe she I found
that extremely stimulating I could go on
and on I have many other personal
questions I know that you now have
started gone into continued painting I
don't think in my opinion that some
people say that that you returned to
painting in reading what you have been
doing in the past I don't think you ever
really left painting knowing you're
actually you never left painting you
never left the the well from which all
of the all these aspirations and all
these dreams sprang from the internal
you you never left that that's that's
where it's coming from the integration
of the interior and the exterior now
it's being manifested on canvas perhaps
but as a painter I don't think that
you've ever taken a break painter
dreams and the social human dreams too
and when this two dreams converge and
synchronising parallel existence and you
may produce something which has a
quality and we
are you a painter too now when I was a
child I started as I mentioned I was
born in the barrio in the railroad yards
of Kansas constant consequently I heard
many of the sounds and so many of the
images of industrial America at the same
time I was I had access to our teacher
when I was four or five years old and I
have always practiced that and I went to
art school I was a young man and then I
also taught at the Kansas City Art
Institute in the foundation department
and always have pursued art and I used
to paint but I think that what happened
and again this is another reason why
your work is extremely attractive to me
because it is also my work is that the
winning of bringing these two things
together art the expression visual
expression of my aspirations being
brought up in an environment with
machines surrounding us etcetera etc it
just never occurred to me that they
could ever be separate they were always
together so I didn't leave one thing to
go to the other I just began the work in
a different kind of way in a more
conscious way and again because of my
own personal lived experience in in a
Mexican household a social change was
extremely important to me and that's the
reason I pursued that the reason that 21
years ago I did not come to visit is
that and perhaps I may have been
mistaken is that at the time I was
teaching at the can City Art Institute
when I received the grant I realized in
reading what your intentions were that
there these were very high ideals and I
shared them
I also know that you mentioned that some
of the Bauhaus influences would be made
use of in the teaching in the classes of
processes I was working with a group of
people in the foundation department that
were using those processes whilst
familiar with them the other part about
the social change I thought that I would
stand back and look my assumption was
that here you are MIT and Harvard were
generally speaking fairly affluent
individuals were in attendance I could
not see at the time why these people
would want to bring social change
predominantly white students upper
middle class and consequently I thought
I'd wait for the next several years I
followed your work very closely in
reading the art form and reading these
various magazines etc and some of your
books and that remained very solid but I
kept looking for things that were coming
out of the Center for Advanced visual
studies and I saw a lot of interesting
things but to my recollection none not
your personal work but none that were
not being done by the fellows that
directly addressed social change or
Noreen's where the intention was
mentioned it was there were ideas the
potential possibly the tools were there
but I never actually saw where they
addressed social change I finally in
1968 put together collaborative of 20
some-odd painters sculptors architects
landscape architects etc in Kansas to do
a 22 million dollar project using your
ideas your concepts and we did it we
build it
but what I had to do which was devious
perhaps but much artists name is devious
was recycle some of the art that was for
commodity recycle it in order to use it
and so I guess it was a process of
deconstruction for the purpose of
reconstruction for the future
since promising I would like to know
more about it I was in fact in take
Kansas Art Institute some maybe five
years ago I think they gave me an
honorary degree something like that I
know I gave the commencement speech but
it was a short exposure so I did not
have too much chance to explore or
exchange in oceans I want to conclude
with an observation which I am certain
after meeting you and talking to you
being here in your own particular
environment your home comment that was
made by an art critic which was as
always it's been a question in my mind
but it's not question no longer this was
this comment was made
by critic by name of Pamela
olara or a Yara depends on how you want
pronounce
an ounce of art news October 1978 page
150 and it states in the article
and the articles MIT Cambridge exhibited
across the river at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and exhibition
will be more experimental artist ERG
chebbi surveyed his paintings
photographs in life sculpture from 1945
to 1947 this is influenced by German
Expressionism and Russian constructivism
Kepesh gave up painting in 1928 39 I
think that's a first error I don't think
that you gave up the idea everything
shifted gears right into her into
another yes shifted because he
considered it to be an insufficient
vehicle for motivating social change he
devoted himself to photography and film
and in filming the Center for Advanced
visual studies in 1967 hope to
facilitate the use of technology as an
artistic medium and the cooperation of
artists and scientists in large-scale
urban projects this goal in her opinion
has produced a few positive results and
Capisce returned to painting is an
effect and admission of failure of his
ideals I do not believe that at a who
was who wrote it Pamela olara alone I
will admit that when I read this article
as part of my research of your work and
I have many many other articles I have a
very thick file on you and your work and
that you knew whatever I know about
myself and definitely more than I know
about you the it was disturbing to me
not in that it cast a doubt about the
validity of your work to bring about
social change to bring about
environmental change but it disturbed me
in that I felt that it was muddying the
waters and that there were many artists
who may read this or
potential artists who may not receive
the full potential of the power of your
work but I found in with many art
critics that the perspective that they
have is one of viewing art as commodity
solely as commodity that it's fragmented
disconnected from social economic and
political realities and this is not the
case in my opinion in the kind of work
that you've been talking about or that
part of the work that attracts me and
that is art as a facet of ideology that
is a part of the fabric that does
recognize this the political economy
that is takes into account the social
economic and political realities in the
process of mediation of your work only
then can you about social change alter
consciousness when you take it place it
keep it in that context obviously to me
she has removed it from that context I
don't know her so I don't know what and
sometimes a fun project segment of one's
Vista you may miss understanding what is
in the background and I don't know her
ideas well I am very familiar with that
type of strategy because I know that
personally in my case except for what my
parents taught me at home I feel that
the person of color that there was an
effort by some to fragment me from the
context from my history my identity and
that type of thing and it works in some
cases
thank you very much you're very welcome
I wish I was more clear and more intense
but as you may know my age I'm not as
fresh and not as alert as you mine must
be no I am over 82 and I feel it off and
on and then ones alertness in this kind
of dialogues it's not as in pinzón or
this fast to the other person but I
enjoyed your question and I wish and I
hope that I will be valid enough and
strong enough to make sense and thanks
for asking me well your work is there
and it's lucid and it's strong and it's
clear and it sends some a message for
the future a direction I hope you are
absolutely right I believe in it but not
everybody thank you again professor
cabbage more than welcome I would like
to know more about your own work I will
mail you the slides etc etc one thing
that I have done unfortunately in terms
of academia I have never allowed
publication in my work and I haven't for
the simple reason that the publication
that normally asked were sort of glossy
national architectural complications not
in that many instances but sometimes an
artist must mediate his or her own work
if the critics are not capable of doing
them justice such as in this case that I
just quoted and in one case where the
slick magazine national architectural
magazine asked to do publish my work I
want to on the condition that I would
explain it and since that permission was
not forthcoming in the way that I wanted
then I did
because that is important the mediation
is extremely important to the work but I
have many slides particularly of this
project that I mentioned to you I made
some artists angry when I published an
article and said that I took artists
commodity and recycled it like junk and
made it meaningful and that
unfortunately made some people upset
some people I recall my father the way
that he in the barrio for many of us
young people didn't go to school for
many reasons they just they had to work
the way that he got us all involved in
interested in going to college first
finishing high school then going to
college was he took us out and he used
the built environment the cultural
landscape the urban form as a teacher he
would deal on with the social spatial
realities of the environment he would
take us to the railroad yards he say
look what that man is doing and look who
he is and then who is the boss then he
would take us downtown
who are the people carrying the
briefcases and driving the cars and who
are the people that don't have jobs etc
so he used the built environment as
teacher that's why I know its power I
know that when I read and when I first
heard your name originally was in the
image of the city by Kevin Lynch and
that book originally came up as an art
book it had a little thing on the back
art now it's architecture and planning
and he was very kind of mentioning your
name
professor capiche and the role you
played in teaching him to see it but
however that first book dealt with form
and not with content and I I was
somewhat perplexed later of course as he
expanded he did deal with that and that
was extremely interesting in the way
that
that devel so yes I have my some of my
work and our mail use copies of the
slides of that project that hi that I
developed the concept and that was the
the coordinator for the entire project
and like I said we had twenty some odd
people had a geographer was my primary
collaborator be you know Kevin Lynch I
met professor Lynch at the UC Berkeley
on the campus at Cal yes I met him
shortly before his death and Appleyard
professor Donald here - yes he as a
matter of fact after I left teaching at
Cal Poly something so peaceful I
resigned teaching there and and it was
very simple as to why resigned I I
mentioned to the Dean that I felt that I
want to take leave because the
curriculum would this was destructive to
my culture
it had to be broadened and destructive
to my community
and I felt that it should be broadened
and I wanna do research in order to to
implement new design new courses very
much in line with they were not new in
terms of the work that you were doing
but I had learned enough from your
writings and so forth that I wanted to
put these things together and I also had
a model that I actually had done and
built nonetheless after I left teaching
I went and lived and worked with mr.
Chavez and United farmworkers as a
matter of fact I have one of the pins
that with your permission oh I've been
meaning to put it on from the beginning
I would put it on - well in that case
let me clear her may I should that after
I left the the teaching for a while I
joined the United Farm Workers for two
years and traveled a lot
around the valley and met the campesinos
first ten I want to know more about the
population in California the rural as
well as the urban population and then
after that I went as it became a
graduate student returned to school 51
years of age at that time I returned for
eight years
can you see Berkeley to take more of the
courses that I had never taken when I
was in school and they were grinding me
out as a technology person very narrow
so I thought I'd go back and take more
liberal arts psychology history and I
had a lot of fun for eight years and
that's when I met professor Donald a
pagar when he was killed in that
terrible accident Athens that is when I
finally left otherwise I think that it
would still be there so Bo again is
wonderful but you suspected we're
sitting here talking about these things
or informally but you your friendship
and your influence with Kevin Lynch he
time and again mention your name wrote
about it we they're close friends and we
their co-director of a project but
became his book in image of she was
image of the city or a lot yes you
received a grant from the Rockefeller
Foundation I think $100,000 or so that
is the big money that is expected what
happened exactly I understand that you
announced we have nothing to report and
then I cannot recall what it was but my
own nature was not a systematic
exploration of anything I think with my
heart and with my eyes and Kevin was a
brilliant men but also brilliant heart
at least a very warm-hearted guy and
that was your that was your way in
actually Kevin was my student for Allah
when I came to MIT just came back from
the war from the Pacific and he took
courses at MIT and took one of my course
but he was actually a giant in his spear
is a great human let me see his family
still practical every month his last
book I think that that was published to
119 a little I don't really remember in
any case he he gave a great deal to all
of us and you know he had this grudge
not tragic in this peaceful grin slept
away from this world he was reading and
died in reading when while he was
reading tell me Who am I see your
paintings is there a local gallery yes I
don't know I would take you to my studio
because I have not fair amount of
material I will have a mini museum in
Budapest and I was just preparing to
send my work I wish I had the energy but
how long guy is staying here till Monday
but like I say again that you read so
much about even books published by MIT
press it says then you took up painting
again and I always say like I never
really because never the reading like
that but they were below that now do you
have this I think I wrote down this
catalogue of MIT if you are willing to
but grab I think that's it this is on
have you ever seen this one as I believe
I've seen four that may interest you
that's first lecture lectures in Mexico
press conferences Teatro de arquitectura
la capitale Mexico you still speak with
always that never leaves you that he may
release left me because I spoke a good
Hungarian and now it's a very rusty
Hungarian I can give you one if you're
in currency yes yes
are you interested in photography - oh
yes
I mean I I I agree with it with what
well you just have to look at the recent
election and know about the power of
video and photography and how things are
Patties but photography the fine art is
it's always been you know one of my
interest I I I don't I have a difficult
time separating the various levels I
just see it at various levels I don't
see that there is a separation the
continuum whether it's photography I
know as a child I used to water in my
dependent yes I know the child at home
my mother one of my tasks was to water
the plants my mother she had hundreds in
coffee cans and I'd water them then I
would draw them I would draw the plants
and then one time our house the
wallpaper was peeing of so I finished
peeing at all off in the kitchen and all
the cracks in the in the plaster I
traced them with with pencils and then I
colored the various patches of plaster
with primary colors like yellow red and
support all over my parents didn't stop
me you know and it looked just like the
plants that I used to water so I that
interest was always there I mean there
was I could explore throughout the house
you know so I never have seen these
things separately it's interesting that
that's not mine
I will
I will mail you a copy of some of this
that's that project that I told you
about would be made as a matter of fact
when I returned to Cal UC Berkeley I did
all my coursework for a graduate degree
I got my masters in architecture there
and then I did all my coursework for a
Landscape Architecture and my thesis is
that was on that project that I did that
urban design project where I used all
these artists and my primary
collaborator was a geographer because I
wanted to get an insight as to the the
social spatial qualities of the the
state but that might be an interesting I
will whatever you could give me a set
background to your own work and this
gives skin that week summary of my own
work Jeanne labarbera I've seen this
before although I don't have a copy of
it now if you wanted oh yes thank you
very much I saw this Jeanne LaBarbara
showed it to me but I didn't before the
libraries but now I'm very fortunate to
have my own copy thanks to unit I kind
of feel as though the cameras and truly
in our practicing now section where
there are private conversation has a
relevance in terms of the video or
whatever here's these I read of a book
by moholy-nagy and when you when you
started the new Bauhaus in Chicago and I
made use of the concepts you had when
you said when you had little stringing
lights over the lake are the Great Lakes
what you were doing consulting work for
the United States government
the idea that if we were invaded to drop
the box into the lake that's a fantastic
idea and so consequently on various
projects I did I was consultant to a to
consultants urban design consultancy in
a Mexican community in Southern
California and I used that idea in the
street where I created some myths and
that and I began to sort of seen it
these myths around because these
freeways were preparing the communities
apart and the Main Street I told this
story and that was interesting how
people picked up on it about how this
dragon came in and how it turned the
Serpent's into stone and not we know
them as freeways but they're winning
serpents that we're eating up it's just
how people elaborate and pick up on
stuff like like that I am only very
sorry that I did not come 21 years ago
to meet you and to and to get a much
closer look at your activity at the
center also sorry for many reason it was
one brain or gray matter gets greed and
greed in the stage of life and I don't
feel I'm as alert now as I supposed to
be with